la pandemia de kobe 19 se agrava en
américa con la mitad de las infecciones
mundiales en la última semana la región
se enfrenta a semanas complicadas debido
a la escasez de recursos y capacidad de
tensiones en hospitales
en toda nuestra región especialmente en
américa del norte y del sur muchos
hospitales están funcionando al límite
de su capacidad o muy cerca de este
vehículo
una situación que llegó al colapso en
manaos brasil donde la falta de tubos de
oxígeno provocó la muerte de decenas de
personas una crisis que espera revertir
con la llegada de unos 136 mil metros
cúbicos de oxígeno desde venezuela
frente a la difícil situación la apuesta
es la vacunación que avanza de manera
lenta e irregular
panamá se convirtió en el sexto país de
la región en iniciar su campaña aunque
con una drástica reducción en las dosis
del fármaco de facer variantes de las
40.000 esperadas llegaron 12 1840 por
problemas de capacidad de producción
yo me siento
oye
y esperanza porque sea la palabra
esperanza
primero tengo la esperanza el país
estamos preparados
ecuador se perfila como la próxima
nación en comenzar su vacunación tras
recibir las primeras ocho mil dosis de
facer por su parte brasil inició la
inmunización en comunidades indígenas
alejadas
argentina autorizó el uso de las tic's
en mayores de 60 años y chile habilitó
el uso de emergencia de la vacuna china
sinovac aunque sólo para personas de
entre 18 y 59 años
[Aplausos]